104.98
russell westbrook
quick to the basket for a jam oh my
goodness vintage
and look at jeremy grant he never saw
him the only guy who saw him was hamadou
diallo
dave cunningham against carmelo anthony
pan picked off by westbrook
[Music]
down deep anthony davis for a dunk
and the lakers lead open out there
there's that steel right there somewhat
telegraph pass and you can't do that
with russell westbrook i mean he is
moving
with
speed and
precision right now they're down
63-54
trailing by nine it's going to be closer
westbrook
time-out taken by the knicks
it's fournier
to walker got by bradley another block
by jordan
he's playing tennis inside westbrook
hold on here comes davis with a
sledgehammer
did we see that
with the clippers and then off to the
races westbrook
finding the streaking a.d
16 in the corner for russell westbrook
quickly on the fly at three westbrook
has the ball here goes carmelo what a
feed
and then gets the long rebound
and finds one of new york's finest
carmelo anthony
with his second field goal
and westbrook who's on fire in the third
[Music]
maneuvering driving and scoring with an
offhand
in a hurry
inside
going in at the other end russell
westbrook
what a red-hot start for the rookie
and a basket by westbrook in a foul
after the pacers
had taken a nine-point lead
fumbles the ball because he's been well
defended shot clock at five
and russell westbrook trims it to a six
point pacers advantage
make two out of the three and go up by
four
penetration all the way to the rim
off the bench for the short-handed kings
team
rush with buddy heel right on him tries
to bully his way in does count it foul
rush rocket
she just keeps working on buddy healed
and buddy reaches in
that's what they call the bailout you
must have just stayed keep your hands to
yourself if you're going to make
[Music]
[Applause]
as soon as he catches he spots him under
the basket no king king close to the
kick
big time down the floor for the lakers
big time coming up on two minutes
cutting down
look at that dive by westbrook where he
throws it down
on the attempt at the rim
i mean that's the way you attack
the basket and then
lebron corner of the key we're a minute
into the overtime gets it to russ
russ goes in the scoop the score
for russell
westbrook
westbrook gets the lakers a four-point
lead with a little scoop shot off the
window and now
again
a lot of standing around for the lakers
now they get into their action rush to a
dude flies to the rim
lakers lead
cairo
but anthony davis got fouled on that
play
alex lynn's there and
looks like he gets fouled to me but they
told me a long time ago you don't have a
whistle so shut up
but i refuse to shut up as anthony davis
puts the lakers on top by two now with
nine seconds
you gotta be very
very concerned about the three-point
shot
[Music]
the four blocks for davis he's gonna get
it underneath throw it in
he threw it in with the left hand
because darren fox is holding the right
hand
little pick and go to the basket and
look at this hole
he kind of tapped it up bagley they're
crashing the glass and getting second
and third opportunities so the lakers
are down but they gave russ free run to
the rim
well you could see that when they left
his hand it was going to be
long shot somebody going to help russ
russ has a triple double and then a
little icing on that cake he puts it up
and in
[Applause]
bucket here imperative
to a d he's got it and a foul
silly foul for sacramento makes it a
four-point game if successful
buddy healed was on the weak side and
that's a play he's definitely in trouble
chick was couldn't be more spot on
that's one of our favorite moments i
know it's maybe your favorite moment
right there one of them you have so many
different so many yeah
oh look at this it goes off of stewart
right back to russ
russ all the way laying up and in
he crossed over on cade cunningham twice
for that layup we get another look at
lebron catching the high pass and then
just catching it and letting him fly for
his fourth three pointer of the ball
game but that foul on avery right we
haven't seen baseball or rondo and seen
them in a couple of games
out for us russian attack mode always
always
and to the basket he goes for another
bucket
has eight rebounds but only four points
russ
with the left hand
[Applause]
another look at
russell westbrook catching the pass
after the gamble going straight to the
rim and throws it up with the left gets
the friendly roll the gamer runs we all
know that's although we're off to a
great start you know the lakers are
going to have their running can we
compound that we can't compound that
would turn over the bad shot selections
see russell westbrook right here but
just a nail pass straight through that
right-handed pass
westbrook in the front court in a hurry
fakes the handoff inside davis with the
punch
i mean the reality of that is that
they've been there
done that and they're gonna lakers just
a half step faster right now davis
calling for it inside
but he did a nice job to knock it away
westbrook with the show and go
monk got his feet set and it's wet
game goes along you see russell
westbrook the way that he's really
impacted the game in the second half is
he got aggressive
ellington was six on the shot glock over
to westbrook
westbrook got downhill
full jelly
she won the pass not making a creative
pass as he taps it ahead and lebron with
the flush and the lakers have caught him
a.d got a controlled tap carmella comes
up with it russ into the frontcourt
streaking davis score it that was a good
heads-up play by russell westbrook
rebound anthony davis ads got 19 six and
three
on the night splitting the defense is
[Applause]
they've been great tonight but they foul
a lot to give up the second most free
throw attempts in the league
and they've already given up 22 tonight
[Applause]
able to get all the way to the rim
no help coming
listen with the way he defends and as
tough as he is if he can shoot anywhere
near those numbers
russell westbrook
beast mode
well 50 points now in the paint on that
resounding slam from russell westbrook
didn't hold the ball he went quickly on
the catch a lot harder to guard when
somebody does that extra feed howard
slams it down
this is great cut great pass and another
one
and howard for the dunk